[Music]
today we are making
pizza
in italy we're in italy i'm making pizza
but more importantly there's been this
controversy on my channel that i need to
address this is how i eat pizza show
picture for some reason this is making
people very upset when it's clearly the
best way to eat the pizza so i thought i
need to convert people i need to show
them how it's done i need to do it in
italy and set a new standard let's begin
first step wash your hands
i will not use the sink
because things are great
okay so i was just about to look where
all the stuff was it turns out mars has
already prepared it for me what a true
italian woman mamma mia she is a perfect
she prepared the pizza i need 400
milliliters uh i need do i need what do
i need
[Music]
combine water yeast and sugar in a small
bowl i need a small bowl what counts as
a small ball and how small can a ball be
until it's no longer a bowl but a cup
something to think about i feel like
this is a small bowl but you know this
is me
water yeast and sugar there's more water
sugar how much water
warm water i gotta heat up the water
[Music]
i found a ball i feel like this is a
normal sized bowl and another thing how
big can a ball be until it becomes a tub
we're genetically disposed to categorize
items in groups
but where those things and then begin
it gets confusing okay we're adding the
water
uh yeast
it's all in italian
is this yeast
[Music]
yeast
[Applause]
this is the yeast i need
two teaspoons what are the
measurements god damn
wait what
oh they come in packages
oh perfect seven grams one sachet they
know they knew that's crazy look you use
the package you need this
oh it fell in the hot water look at this
is that half half a liter guys do you
think this is half a liter how is this
gonna
two glasses is one half a liter you
might see it
it says two glasses is half a liter
okay it's half a liter i can tell
what don't give me that lick i know what
i'm doing okay i'm adding the yeast now
set aside for five minutes until foamy
what do i mix it yeast and sugar small i
need sugar
a pinch of caster sugar castor sugar
this is cancer sugar you're telling me
this is caffeine
this is cancer sugar
a pinch
you want you want that sweetness it's a
hidden italian secret
i assume you mix it
it's been five minutes i replaced it
with a small bowl because
sometimes when they say small bowl they
actually mean small bowl it's supposed
to be foamy
it's not foamy
what does that mean i don't know combine
flour and salt okay in a large bowl
this time you get the large bowl i'm so
excited to use the large bowl
four cups of plain sour flour i don't
have measurements this is
so annoying
i can eye this i can hide this i have no
choice but to eye this now i think mine
okay
that's four cups let's say do you think
there's four cups yeah she said she said
absolutely
no that's not four cups
how do you know by looking but this is
huge
this is not like a representation of a
cut yeah that's four
no yeah it's four they mean deciliters
right i need measurements
what is a cup okay google what is a cup
how much is deciliter according to end
memo cup left right arrow dl1 cup equals
2.5 deciliters 2.5 deciliter okay i need
more
this is a sugar
[Applause]
wait wait wait wait what's the pasta how
much is in this one kilo
i don't need the kilos i need them
i need like half of this roughly
right
okay then i need the salt one teaspoon i
can do a teaspoon i can do that one
teaspoon
well then
teaspoon okay
i did it add the yeast mixture and oil
okay i'm adding the yeast
and oil how do i add oil in this bro 660
milliliters that's a lot of oil for a
pizza right baby
is that enough
i got a measurement how much was this is
impossible
this is not our house by the way oh it's
so hot how i don't know if i'm supposed
to use my hand i just kind of did
it it feels good i will say that it
feels real good
hmm it looks like though yeah yeah yeah
this looks like though use a round
bladed knife in a cutting motion to mix
the mixture until the mixes combined use
your hands to bring the dough together
well well well
dude this doesn't look bad
this looks like dough to me yeah this is
totally dope i made though from i i made
it from i hard mode literally impossible
mode how gooey should it be like if i do
that does that
is that yes why are you taunting me i
need help i need help help me you're
italian we're gonna add a little bit
more flour for for luck good luck good
luck flour everyone uses that right it
kind of separates
i don't make food i don't make pizza i'm
swedish we don't have make pizza
actually we do we put banana on our
pizza should we do that
feather
i've never seen you so
angry
or unsatisfied
do we have banana i kind of want to try
it i mean if we're making a cursed pizza
yeah we're doing a cursed pizza now
oh it's coming off
what's a
oh no it's getting gunky again
i'm sure it's fine right i'm sure it's
fine what do you want to do healthy no
no that's fine i i need to do this i
just need guidance
use your hands to bring them together in
a bowl brush a bowl lightly with oil
turn the dough into a lightly flour
floured surface and knead for 10 minutes
until smooth and elastic
why do i need two bowls i already have a
bowl i have a bowl right here it's
telling me to go with another bowl
that's done that makes no sense brush a
bowl lightly with oil i'm just gonna
follow the recipe at this point
see how it splatters everywhere stupid
sink heatsink
okay brush with oil did i pick the
hardest thing to ever make
brush with oil
let's use my hands
there you go brush with oil
okay turn the dough into a lightly
floured surface
lightly floured surface
this is the sugar stop taking the sugar
our flour is red don't make the goddamn
sugar red stupid hey i hate you really
god damn it
all right
lightly flour knead for 10 minutes until
smooth and elastic
[Music]
beautiful
mamma mia
get all your anger out yeah sega that's
right
stupid pizza
hey kinda
huh you think you're better than me
what
you're glad you're clean
good
ten minutes yeah i gotta do this
is this when they do the spinning
huh
this isn't eating
this is illegal am i going to person
oh yeah
[Music]
this is fun i like pizza
ah
i left too hard out
and my ribs
it's getting sticky now stupid sugar
every time it tricks me
this is me
when i see a bad sink
oh god damn it
this thing punched back god damn
that was good
no
nate you can't don't speak to me like
i'm a dog
mice is telling me to do this motion
no
what like that
is that it that's ridiculous why would i
do that
this is so much more fun
let this be a warning
if any youtuber wants to fight me
this is what you got
got nothing
okay
i think it's been 10 minutes
either that but i'm bored oh
good thing i was where i had the new
pewdiepie rhino shield case link in the
description they got black friday sale
check it out anyway i have to use my
thumb print
and it's all covered in dough
okay so now turn the dough into the
liverpool knead for 10 minutes until
smooth and elastic yeah i think so place
the prepared bowl and turn to coat in
oil
okay then you also after abusing it for
10 minutes you give it a kiss
it's okay
i love you feels good to kiss that
actually
do you want to kiss him no
hey guy you want a kiss
no
no all right here we go
bye
see you in 30 minutes gotta cover it
with plastic
this will be a challenge you can use the
kitchen towel
is that it
all right
see you in 30 minutes
it's been an hour all right yeah it's
reason quite a bit
as maybe i put too much oil but yeah oh
it's it's all slimy now yeah
so it don't get stuffed that's why you
put the oil
nice
i did it
dude it's so fluffy
it's supposed to be that fluffy it's
very airy
oh it's so light now
love it so now what do we do now we make
the pizza
right
do we have one of those
oh
it's time
so that's how they do in italy when the
moon hits your eyes
pizza pizza pizza bye
i'm scared
do you want a pizza really
you will eat my pizza
there's too much pressure if
you eat my pizza but then i'll make two
to two of them
you are not the guardian i know it looks
dumb but it's kind of working
we use the centrifugal force
what are they called the pizzeria makers
here
pizzaioli
they're all studying me now
how we make a pizza so good he's
impossible
so much talent
what do you think of that
yeah
i'm so stressed
my entire future pizza making rides on
this pizza man
all right so this will be your pizza
she doesn't know but i'm gonna make it
into a heart that's gonna be really cute
she doesn't know
i was going to make yours into a heart
but i can't do it
bro i can't even make it into a heart
[Music]
all right well mine's just kind of look
like a pizza
no way look what marxian wanted me to do
how on earth will i do that
i can try what's that in the middle
maybe a tomato ah a little bit get out
of here get out of here don't even don't
even steven me man
okay so now i will add the tomato sauce
i have not made my own sauce which
marzia was kind of scuffing at me for
i'm sorry i didn't know
so sorry i mean
look i made my own sauce there we go
i forgot to heat the oven
damn it making pizza sucks i'm never
doing this again okay we put the tomato
now the mozzarella
mozzarella do it i've never used my
strawberry before how do i use them
why are they in these
is it water inside
me okay of course
i never used mozzarella i told you bro
ew what is it a baby inside what is this
oh
what's the name what do i do with this
don't shower it no you don't wash it
and i just put
yes
what tell me what you
so rude
this is for the snack video you're being
sad i don't know cut it do i tear it or
cut it i'm gonna use the scissors i
don't even care
no you use this for dog's feet
but it's clean it's clean it's clean
it's clean
you're not telling me you're so rude
this is funny to you this seems normal
to me pete comedy for italians happening
apparently
so weird
it's like chicken is that enough do you
want more on yours
way more apparently okay
do you want the whole thing seems like a
lot
this video is stressing me out man i
can't do this
there you go that's enough
now they go into oven and then i will
show how a pizza eat
it actually doesn't look
not that bad my says cooking underneath
i don't know how it's doing down there
but mine is okay give it a few more
minutes
i think i spoke too soon
we have a problem some mars is pizza
oh god
it's more like a brea i made bread
it's so thick
but like my pizza
i did it i moved it it kind of looks a
bit cursed i'm not gonna lie it looks a
little close to kay's kitchen cooking
i'm sorry but it makes yours look so
good merci
[Applause]
[Music]
you're so cute you like it you actually
it's
no i a little
mozzarella is still like you see the the
water it wasn't mine for mine really
yeah but mine what about my mine is
watery too yes
should i keep them longer let me try a
piece
it just looked like orange i didn't want
the mozzarella to burn
look at that i think you usually make
like smaller pieces of mozzarella so
they melt easier and they don't
all right
anyway you eat it from the center that's
the whole point of this video
oh mine is a thick crust
[Music]
it tastes like the lunch school pizza
mine is pink
don't judge my pizza how dare you what
you're gonna tell me pizzas aren't pink
now
it's actually not it's not bad
it's not good
it's not gray
i think it would be very good if you
just like to stretch anymore yeah you
live and you learn and hopefully you
learn that this is the correct way to
eat the pizza
i'll definitely do better if i do it
again nothing like washing down your
cursed pizza with some g fuel
buy one get one sale happening right now
um
don't eat the crust because the crust is
the worst part of the pizza why would
anyone eat the crunch well
yours is gonna love all the time
well
the thing about eating like this i've
asked italians actually italians your
friends
or my friends too sure i was like can i
eat
can i eat like this and they're like
yeah no one cares italians say this
[Music]
but marcia isn't steaming from her head
right now when she's seeing this right
you don't count no one cares this is the
best way to eat pizza
i mean if it's the drink it's not the
best way what do you mean it's not the
best one
we invented knife and pork
just so we can eat pizza like this you
don't believe me have they do it do they
have pizzas in china
no they know what's the hygiene rating
five out of five high generating now
you know i've eaten the best part of the
pizza i can decide hey do i want to go
overseas do i want to explore
the edges of the cross i don't know
maybe i will maybe i won't
that's a fun way of eating pizzagate to
everyone that disagrees
eating pizza with knife and fork bro
just try it some stuff you gotta try
until you know did you know that you
liked water before you tried it i hate
water
the best part about eating a pizza like
this is that you can do this afterwards
you can wear it like that oh no that's
gross
there you go pewdiepie pizza how many
italians rating do you get three out of
five three out of five let's go
pewdiepie pizza
booty
all right that's it see ya
actually that's not it you know what
i'm feeling adventurous
you're gonna be putting coke no it's you
feel as a kid i would always think
yeah
that's myself pizza that's cursed
[Music]